alex smith wants to play very badly
for the washington football team on
saturday night that's an nbc game the
buccaneer is coming to town
good news for wft alex smith
was limited in practice on wednesday
with a calf injury an injury that kept
him from practicing tuesday and that
caused ron rivera to suggest maybe a
quarterback rotation limited in practice
also we're running back antonio gibson
with turf toe and receiver terry mclaren
with the ankle problem that had him in a
walking boot just a week and a half ago
so the pieces may be falling together
for washington
not that it will matter according to the
odds makers who still have the
buccaneers as eight point favorites but
look at you know
we've seen it anything can happen no
anything can happen right things happen
stuff happens and if they can get
consistent pressure on tom brady
and turn turnovers and mistakes and
screw-ups into points
maybe it'll be close in the fourth
quarter and uh you can't you just can't
rule out anything you can't
right we would have never matter how
good you think a team is you can't
exactly
i mean we were never in a million years
thought the jets were gonna go to la and
dominate the rams
we never would have thought washington
was gonna go to pittsburgh and beat the
steelers that night they did
so you're exactly right and
you know again part of playing
washington and tom brady and all that is
is yes avoid disaster from that front
four
you have to almost be a little
conservative that way because they they
can win the game
but those injuries you know mclaren and
antonio gibson
man they're big they're the two best
offensive players on that football team
mclaren is a game changer now he doesn't
have a quarterback necessarily that can
take advantage of
his speed and what he can do but he
still is going to scare the hell out of
a defense and antonio gibson
phenomenal but man he to me on sunday
night looked
nowhere near 100 percent nowhere he
turf toe for a running back man
forget it like that is a brutal brutal
injury for those guys and it looked like
he was running on one leg so that that's
gonna be
you know something to look out for and
then hey for wft
you know hey wtf with the alex smith
situation
okay okay like come on i we
we can't throw him out there and don't
do that what we just saw last week
that was you know that was survival that
wasn't really playing quarterback
that was survival that was like let me
find the first guy that's remotely open
and throw it i'm not going to wait for
anything else i'm not going to get hit
i can't run and move if we're talking
about rotating quarterbacks
then just start taylor heineke that's
all there is to it
you're answering the question right
there i mean if you're talking about
rotating
you're telling yourself listen to it
you're saying
one guy's not healthy enough to play i
know we're trying to pay him respects
because he's the comeback player of the
year and all the things he's done
but it to me makes no sense to play him
if he looks the way he did last week
yeah that's going to be a real challenge
for washington because he's clearly the
better option he's got great playoff
experience
he's been around for so long and he puts
you in a better position to win and it
gets back to the analysis we've had with
other quarterbacks
what percentage below 100 are you
willing to tolerate having your starter
b
that's right versus the 100 back up in
taylor heinecke in this case and i
i but you're right if you can't play the
whole game
that tells you maybe it should just be
heineken and you should just come up
with the best offensive
exactly you can unless they're hoping to
stress todd bowles defense
to be ready for both guys things like
that don't work very often and i don't
think it'll work for washington
i think anything other than alex smith
all game long is going to make it very
hard
for washington to overcome the
buccaneers the seahawks trying to
overcome
the los angeles rams that's the middle
game
on saturday and the seahawks beat the
rams a couple of weeks ago
but the rams have done very well against
seattle in recent years and one of the
things pete carroll the seattle coach is
trying to do is keep the cards close to
the vest about the availability of
safety jamal adams
adams apparently didn't get the memo
here he is yesterday addressing the
question of whether or not
he will be playing with an injured
shoulder on saturday afternoon
no question in my mind i'm playing man
yeah hey look
as long as these legs are moving man um
as long as you know my faith is with the
man upstairs which is very strong
i'm gonna be out there so there's there
was never no doubt in my mind that i
wasn't playing so
let's get that out there i'm full go
well and if they win hopefully he'll
light the right end of the cigar
when he celebrates after the victory
after the last win over the rams
lighting the wrong end of the cigar or
at least trying to he's got a hand
injury also it's the shoulder that's the
problem jeron reed defensive tackle has
an oblique injury
and chris carson foot injury all
returned to practice on wednesday for
the seahawks so that's good news as they
get ready on a short week one
day less that's the thing all these
teams played sunday they got to turn
around and play saturday for these three
playoff games chris
and they need jamal adams oh even with
with
john wolford possibly likely whatever at
quarterback
we're going to talk about that in a
minute they need jamal adams yeah no
no doubt about it i mean first off this
is why you get jamal adams just like
what you see in the price i mean he's
going
it doesn't matter i mean oh hey my
shoulders hanging by you know a ligament
no big deal i'm playing that's the kind
of guy he is that is
he is so crazy and reckless on the
football field mike that when i watch
him
on film i just sometimes go man
he might have to dial it back a little
bit because his career might not
last as long he's so unbelievably all
over the place and has no regard for his
body
yeah they need him the energy he brings
to that defense
and this specific team mike he's even
more important
with the rams and what they do we all
right the speed sweeps the inside zone
the bootlegs
he's the guy there on the edge of the
defense a lot of times to run down the
speed sweep
oh here comes the bootleg out the back
side oh wait i got the guy in the flat i
got to cover the crosser
let alone he is their greatest talent
on their on their defense and the guy
that they can
put in the most awkward positions you
know you
they disguise through jamal adams you go
oh you know wait they're they're not
gonna bring this blitz and blitz this
guy and leave jamal adams on this
receiver one on one
oh wait they will cause that's right
he's he's so talented he can play cover
corner
he can blitz he can play linebacker so
yes they do need him and jaron reads a
big deal too
uh because you gotta that rams offense
and even though it's not sexy and fun
it's effective that little combination
mcveigh and mcgay has with golf or
or wolford it was just 11 days ago that
rams quarterback jared goff
suffered a dislocated thumb that he
popped back into place and kept going
he had surgery the next day there are
screws in the thumb
they're not ruling out the possibility
of goth being able to play in that game
here is sean mcvay coach of the rams on
goff's ability to practice and
potentially ability to play
he went through what a normal practice
would entail ball handling
throwing some routes on air getting a
little bit of work off to the side when
the defense was going and
got some stuff in uh you know with our
offensive guy so he got what
what a normal practice would entail
so he's practicing and of course that
look they're not going to telegraph to
the world what
what is going to happen with jared goff
they they want the seahawks to be
guessing is it going to be goff is it
going to be wolford it doesn't i don't
know how it doesn't really matter
because the offense is fairly basic it's
not like all of a sudden they're going
to have some guy out there that can do
all sorts of
special things at the quarterback
position like a patrick mahomes yeah
but you know okay yeah and chris here's
the problem for the rams
if they win this game with john wolford
a quarterback no doubt that gives life
to this argument that they shouldn't
have given jared goff 33.5 million a
year
no doubt i mean i think that's why jared
goff is going to play it all
at all you know exhaust all avenues to
get out there because
he's going to be aware of that narrative
and i you know honestly
i i what i want to see is is are the
rams
going to sacrifice maybe losing the game
just to not let that narrative become a
real thing too
are they going to just throw him out
there even though they go i don't know
if it's really going to work
but we don't want to have to answer
those questions that is going to be very
interesting to watch
mike you said it the offense didn't
change one bit last week
there's nothing that changes maybe a few
things at the line of scrimmage like we
talked about with tempo
and like yeah i don't want to do this
with my young quarterback who hasn't
played a lot
but the plays themselves were the same
plays you always see
and you know the thing that i would
think like the rams got to be a little
concerned about
is watching the game from two weeks ago
against the seattle seahawks
with jared goff with the bad thumb jared
goff is not a real great thrower of the
football when his thumb is normal
and it's not it goes way bad when it's
when it when it's not
normal he played horrible in their last
game
against the seattle seahawks there in
week 16. i mean
horrible it was a pitiful performance
and that's got to be in their mind a
little bit to go
wait he wasn't good before he was
injured and then he got injured and it
looked even a lot
worse and are we really going to do that
as a football team
that is going to be worth you know the
price of watching here this this week to
see how that unfolds
running back cam acres with an ankle
injury was a full participant in
practice
that's good news for the rams and even
better news andrew whitworth their
left tackle and one of their offensive
captains plans to start on saturday he's
been
out since week 10 with a torn mcl in his
knee he's back
he's ready to go not that the offensive
line was horrible without him but that
that's good you get a guy like that
who's got playoff experience
back in the fold gives you a little bit
of a lift it gives you a little bit of
boost and you got somebody there who can
maybe
help give a little more protection to
john wilford if he ends up playing
quarterback at all because you know the
possibility is
goff goes or tries to go and
can't and at some point wolford has to
come in
yeah you're exactly right and you know
whitworth yes
is you know he's a guy again he's a left
tackle that you could just put him
somewhere and go
all right we don't have to worry about
him we don't have to worry about
anything
you know we don't have to help him or do
anything like that and
hey we've said it the seahawks defense
this is not the same defense we saw in
the first half of the year they're
really damn good
you know they're good up front they give
you a lot of different looks and things
like that
to where they're gonna have to rely on
the run game and have guys like
whitworth just
be physically dominant at times if they
want to move the football
against what the seahawks are doing
right now so you know he's amazing
you know as amazing as it is that tom
brady's playing at the level
he is at 43. you know whitworth is
is what is he 38 39
to be doing that at left tackle is every
bit as impressive as what brady's doing
at 43. i mean to be able to play at that
level and still do what he does is
mind-boggling uh so that's cool for him
glad to see him out there
yeah and look just like with drew brees
this could be it for andrew whitworth
and there was some
commentary yesterday from aaron donald
they have a high degree of confidence
and you don't hear talk like that from
aaron donald he's very confident that
they have all the pieces of the puzzle
in place
to basically finish the job they started
two years ago
when they got to the super bowl and lost
it and
and and there was a point this season
where
the rams the best team in the nfc i mean
he's gone sure is it the saints and is
it the packers
is it the buccaneers is it the seahawks
is it the rams
these nfc playoffs should
be awesome yes and on saturday
in that middle game we will see two
teams playing both of whom are good
enough
yeah to get to the super bowl they are
and one is going to get kicked to the
curb
you're right that's amazing that's what
the best thing is when we get the best
teams in the playoffs and you know you
made the point yesterday i know we got
the nfc east they've ruined a little of
that story but
i think other than that we did get the
best teams in the playoffs which are
going to lead to great watches and
you're right
even though we got questions about both
of these teams right now rams or
seahawks
you know we still know there are tough
battle-tested teams
who have played a lot of close
meaningful playoff playoff type games to
where we've seen them win
too many to just think oh they're not as
good as the bucks this year so they
can't beat them or the packers or
anything like that
no way no way not with sean mcvay you
know and what they do on the offensive
side of the ball and really the big
thing is
their defense is special it's special
scheme and they have special players who
can make plays to help them win football
games
just on that side of the ball so i'm
with you mike that's
that's secretly a really fun game that i
think gets
lost in the shuffle a little bit this
weekend because it's the third time
we're seeing it this year
and think about this if tampa bay beats
washington as it should and if the
saints beat the bears as they
should it will be either seahawks at
saints
or rams at packers in
the divisional round and either one of
those games that's enough to keep
the head coach of the home team up late
no doubt
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports